la mort de françoise dolto celle que
l'on avait surnommé la grand-mère de la
psychanalyse avait 79 ans influencé par
jacques lacan elle était l'une des
meilleures spécialistes de la
psychologie de l'enfant par ses ouvrages
ses émissions de radio elle avait su
mettre à la portée du plus grand nombre
ces méthodes d'approché de compréhension
du monde de l'enfance anna la bouche ce
sont les enfants qui ont une curiosité
extraordinaire et une curiosité qui
n'est pas seulement
de ce qu'il voit mais de ce qu'ils
perçoivent ils perçoivent très très
finement au toucher et à l'audition ils
perçoivent les nuances de la voix de
quelqu'un qui leur parle juste ou faux
et c'est pour ça que c'est si important
que les parents ne répète pas les
paroles qu'on leur dit qu'il faut dire
aux enfants parce qu'ils s'entendent
très bien que c'est dû répéter que ce
n'est pas de leur cru mais quand vous
commencez à parler à des bébés même lui
comme si c'était comme s'ils allaient
pouvoir vous répondre on fait du quand
même beaucoup se moquer de vous il était
un peu naze and services
on s'amusait de me voir parler avec les
enfants c'est ici dans ce bureau que
pendant 40 ans françoise dolto a appris
le langage des enfants pour mieux le
faire partager à leurs parents mais
aussi parce que pour elle une seule
cause compter celles des enfants
pédiatre et psychanalyste françoise
dolto avait la passion de l'écriture
elle a reçu ici rue saint jacques des
milliers de parents souvent désemparés
ce qu'elle voulait avant tout que le
monde de l'enfance ne soit plus étranges
et aux adultes il a quand même marqué un
tournant dans l'histoire de la façon
dont on conçoit
le psychisme des gens et puis dans ton
compte que la place des enfants le
respect d'un fond je crois que je crois
que si elle si elle voulait laisser un
message c'était respecter les enfants et
quelques jours il a failli
défaillir aimé te disais que tu m'as
pauvres
que cette expérience avait avait
renforcé non seulement en mesure de bien
vivre ses derniers moments et dans le
calme de la tante de ce qu'est la voir
après